hey guys this is dennis the founder take
care and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of The Walking Dead Season
four Episode four indifference yes or
also known as the let's go shopping
episode yeah yeah I gotta go get gross
this is Walking Dead's version of how to
get groceries yes the whole episode is
basically I mean we only followed to
like groups of people with auld Rick and
Carol yep and their their trip to go
find medicine in the suburbs and then
you had Tyrese show Darrell and Bob
trying to find also poor bub finding
medicine they don't know and and that
whole thing but really that's all the
episode was not a whole lot happened I
mean other than the ending right in I
don't know if there be a little too
literal with the imagery the episode is
called indifference and Carol is
indifferent to hurt her you know
murdering those people and saying it had
to be done obviously Rick you know get
to that later Rick had his own opinion
on that but yeah I don't not really that
much happen this episode they went
shopping yeah yeah I mean they were just
Rick and Carol went to the suburbs to
find stuff and Tyrese and the rest of
that group were still over they were on
that they were originally on that
mission to find the you know the
antibiotics and stuff like that so with
Rick and Carol the whole time it was
just the unspoken thing about how Rick
knows that she killed Karen and David oh
and him not really saying anything about
it but carol kind of getting not mad or
angry but she's just cut she's like
nervous in a way like why isn't Rick's a
meat man you know and of course finally
at the end he kind of tells her how he
really feels yeah I mean she its way I
kind of almost want to say it's a little
hypocritical they've all done bad things
they've all died mean Carol because it
wasn't seen when they showed Rick in the
beginning now he didn't see it happened
but they're in his head he's imagining
Carol stabbing the girl on the back of
the head while she's coughing you know
and there's you know she didn't even
give him a chance according to Rick you
know they could have gotten out of it
but I think coded the right thing this
is an environment where you kind of do
what you have to do and they've all done
that it seems kind of crazy to kind of
throw her to the curb you know I don't
know I don't know how Gerald's gonna
react to that well I guess his girl the
quite the question now is what does Rick
tell the rest of the group when he goes
back and we're assuming that that Daryl
Tyrese Michonne and Bob get back right
to the prison and at least some of the
people will survive what does Rick tell
them about what happened to Carol
because they'll be especially you know
what where why is Carol gone did she die
or did she take off why would she take
off she was taking care of these two
little girls you know which she had like
this weird conversation with one of them
at the beginning no possum don't call me
Mom yeah I mean those we were talking
about this we thought that Rick would
just you know side with Carol just or at
least keep it a secret you might not
agree with it or like Carol's anything
you might not like it we just kind of
keep on the down low so you know Tyrese
isn't go kill her o war he's gonna go
back and tell everyone I'm truth right
what happens and Daryl might not believe
I think Tyrese will believe it oh yeah
yeah he's willing to accept any truth
right yeah cuz he's easy and already
like kill his many nosy hey oh yeah i
mean he's either lose a loose cannon
obviously saw their show and he won't
look like why didn't you let go but i
like that moment and again I guess
skipping over to michelle's character
that we all get more development with
him a show that was I think the strength
of this episode Michonne's character you
know and he asked like well how come you
keep chasing the governor and she's like
I don't know she had to come to grips at
the end she does saying you're right i
need to stop doing this I mean Michonne
has been better developed a season
that's why yeah she's a much more
likable character right yeah a little
more death to her oh boy yeah yeah and
then of course we get the back history
of Bob yeah bean I mean we already knew
he was an alcoholic but I guess those
look at the books yeah he's gonna get
the books good alcohol he need a bowl do
to Daryl and then him fighting for the
the basically the bottle though well
he's good almost getting them killed to
like in the process it's one thing if
you want to almost get yourself killed
over something like that but getting
other people involved I think this isn't
seen in this episode I'm not sometimes
the emotional overtone
to the show they kind of I don't know
that I think they're trying to like
impact you a little bit like so when
Bob's in the in the shop and they're
shopping as they did the whole episode
and there's that the old man died or
he's dead he's got a zombie it looked at
the pictures start playing like the slow
piano music it's very you know quiet you
know just very emotional I'm like are
you trying to like make me feel emotion
it's like yeah I get people have lost
families and do this for what four years
now you know a few seasons now it's like
I get it like I don't know if they're
trying to put over the top of that yeah
we've seen it before and also you know
it's hot it's harder to feel sympathy
for this already turn zombie right
character but looking at some pictures
you don't even know it's like I'll have
a connection to those people yeah i mean
i'm sorry i just did i mean i don't mean
to be cold but it didn't feel anything
in that moment I feel like it was trying
to tug something out of me there now and
then back on the Rick and Carol I when
they're in the suburbs they find this
young couple right that wants to join
their group and Rick make the decision
to let them in yes the three questions
yeah yeah even though they probably
weren't the best suited I mean you could
tell Leiter on drugs yeah they were like
the stoners in the post-apocalyptic
world I don't know where they found all
the weed but but yeah it wasn't this
smartest decision no he's made and Carol
is kind of questioning that and of
course you know that one you you could
maybe feel a little bit more for these
two characters and then later you find
you know can you feel real bad for you
see the leg I just assume they're dead
or turned to zombies alright nothing
what I soon they didn't seem that
crucial that we would need to see them
again mhm you know I mean obviously herb
and her leg was off but I mean let's say
the guy still out there me I don't think
they're that crucial to the story that's
the thing i wasn't i wasn't sure
inception was trying to tell me i mean
if it is just like the title says
indifference and that Carol is
indifferent to murder and different like
how we've lost our humanity I think this
show has done that enough to tell us
that like yeah like the governor showed
us people do dark things people do crazy
things to stay alive seeing Rick and his
people do that over and over again
doesn't really do anything for me in the
motion yeah I mean
it's getting you know there's a lot of
things that are repetitive and they're
also just elongated I mean in terms of
this episode you know could have been
like a 20 minute 30 minute episode how
much stuff that actually happened wasn't
that much I mean to see anything in the
prison of those in the very beginning
all right and and then the two groups
really were basically almost doing the
same thing at different locations yeah
it's also i mean i don't want to i guess
i gotta give credit I think the actors
do a good job on off Carol's character
even that little car the cartridge in
the beginning with Lizzie little girl
and Carol it was great acting by both
the child actually a great job and you
know Carol it a great job but it's like
I get the point it's like we're in this
world morality is blurred we have to
make tough decisions you gotta kill when
you got a kilt like yeah I get it like I
don't need to hear that again like I
need something more we need those
situations new dynamics and and how
people interact and do it that's why you
know towards the end okay we we get
something with Rick and Carol now yeah
all right kick to the curb Rick gives
her a bunch of supplies and says okay
get that F Adam right yeah who knows
maybe that's the spin-off show right
yeah Carol on the road hey she takes a
car heads last hey west coast and
musical little cruising yeah that's and
that's the spin-off show I don't know uh
but I don't know I I don't think that I
don't think this is the last we've seen
of Carol no no no she'll she'll be back
sit back it's it just took a while to
get to that point of her eggs anybody I
think she'll be back I mean that was I
guess maybe the highlight of this
episode was Carol getting kicked out
that's that's that's gonna be the big
the bus that's gonna be a talk you know
she'll be back and then now is
Michelle's like accepted that the trail
has gone cold governor you know the airs
gonna pop up yeah now he's gonna once
she stops looking for yeah he's gonna
pop up right all right yeah so I guess
that's it I mean it's nothing really
much more to talk about in this episode
this is what happens when the walking
dead has to go shop yeah I got a bunch
of tweets and facebook messages from
people as as we were watching a show
about like man I don't know if I'm into
the show anymore this episode is really
slow and I heard a lot of complaints
about this episode so letting us know
what you think were you bored by or
game too repetitive what do you think
you pleasure comments below on our
website thing CARICOM or on our youtube
channel that's think hero pro make sure
you subscribe to that those who come
chat us up on Twitter talk to Dennis and
I about anything Walking Dead related
other TV shows that are filling your
your Sundays come chat with us at think
hero I'm at Griffin de and we have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com / 10
Carol fans and make sure you like that
page and it spread the word share our
videos like you guys up and tweet our
videos out alright guys thanks